partout au canada le nombre
d'hospitalisations cosy par des
blessures est en baisse sauf dans une
seule catégorie celle des accidents de
vélo ça m'étonne pas moi j'étais victime
d'accident club deux fois des gens qui
parlaient sur leur cellulaire qui
n'était pas le flash en 2020 21 plus de
cinq mille cyclistes ont été
hospitalisés une augmentation de 25 % à
l'échelle du canada et de 20 pour cent
au québec on dénombre également plus de
quarante trois mille visites de
cyclistes à l'urgence une hausse de 36%
plus de cyclistes et peut-être aussi les
interpellés sont pas autant conscient et
les cycles et sur la côte on croit que
c'est la popularité croissante du vélo
qui explique cette augmentation marquée
des accidents mais aussi la pandémie qui
encourage les canadiens à faire plus
d'activité physique peut-être son passé
beaucoup de temps à l'extérieur et ont
pu assez de nouvelles activités comme le
vélo qu'il n'aurait pas nécessairement
le passé et cela a pu a entraîné une
augmentation des brasseurs sans grande
surprise l'institut nous apprend aussi
que deux fois plus d'hommes que de
femmes ont été hospitalisées à la suite
d'un accident de vélo parce que les
filles on est plus attentive aux règles
ou on n'y suis plus pro vélo québec ces
nouvelles données sont la preuve qu'il
faut accélérer la consolidation du
réseau de pistes cyclables pour
sécuriser les secrets il ya deux choses
sont importants la première c'est la
construction d'infrastructures cyclables
séparées la circulation aux siens mais
la deuxième chose c'est l'abaissement de
la vitesse des automobiles dans l'avenir
dit il il faudra aussi surveiller le
dossier dr rapide et silencieux vélos à
assistance électrique un moyen de
transport peu réglementés même s'ils
causent beaucoup de frictions sur les
voies cyclables
lorsqu'on a des enfants sur une piste
cyclable puis des vélos qui roulent à 32
kilomètres a certainement pas
compatibles c'est ce qui laisse en fait
maintenant l'expérience presque
quotidiennement pour ça que je me suis
vient d'acquérir un petit rétroviseurs
qui est absolument indispensable
mais même à ça aujourd'hui à main qui
m'a doublé être vraiment vite j'ai eu
très peur en 2020 21 près de 800
cyclistes canadiens ou subi une lésion
cérébrale à la suite d'une chute à vélo
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal